ذكرت مراسله الجزيره ان الاحتجاجات
الشعبيه المطالبه برفع الاغلاقات في مختلف
المدن الصينيه توقفت وسط تعزيزات الامنيه
مشدده في العاصمه بجين وفي شنغهاي
واظهرت صور انتشارا مكثفا لقوات الشرطه في
مدينه شنغهاي حال دون خروج احتجاجات
مناهضه لقيود كرونه وافدت وكاله ورويترز
نقل عن مصادر من المشاركين في الاحتجاجات
ان السلطات الصينيه اجرى التحقيقات مع بعض
المحتاجين وطالبت مشاركين في المظاهرات
بالموتور امام مراكز الشرطه
من جانب اخر خففت سوتات واجراءات العزل
المتعلقه بكرونا في عدد من الاقاليم
من جلد السلطات ومدينه تيجوان جو الجنوبيه
البلاد تخفيفه اجراءات مكافحه فيروس
كورونا عبر السماح للاشخاص الذين يعملون
في مناطقات تصنف على انها عاليه الخطوره
بالعوده الى مدنهم بعد استكمال الخطوات
الاحترازيه وتهدف الخطوه الى تقليل
الكثافه السكانيه في المناطق الاكثر تضرنا
بالفايروس من اجل الحدي من انتقاله وقد
طلب اكثر من 10,000 شخص عالق- خارجه من
دونهم السلطات بالسماح لهم بالعوده الى
منازلهم
وقدستانفت السلطات الصحيه في مدينه شنغهاي
الصينيه اجراءات فحوص جماعيه للسكان
الكشفي عن فيروس كورونا كما تواصلت الفحوص
الجماعيه للسكان في العاصمه بتجينا ويتفشى
فيروس كورونا في الصين رغم الجهود التي
يبدلها معظم سكان البلاد للوقايه من
العدوى عبر الالتزام بسياسته صفر كفيل
المفروض القضاء على جميع المرض والابقاء
على ضوابط حدوديه صارمه